hannah and dez congratulations
thank you bryce thank you bryce can we
see that ring hannah
i actually i don't know when to wear it
and when not because i'm scared of
losing it but um
i'm wearing it today that's a podcast
episode in itself when to take off your
ring and when not to
there's a lot of rules i wasn't prepared
for dez i mean you
kind of first caught the attention of
the people who know hannah from the
bravo world from this interview you did
while she was filming this season at
summer house where you said
i've fallen in love with it with a woman
during the pandemic too so
all in all despite the fact that all
these memes are like i can't wait for
2020 to be over
like 2020 will be the year that changed
my life so is this
a stairs well you can never say miriam
all we have is today
can't predict the future but i i would
be confident in saying
that i will certainly make an effort
that it is it because it feels like it
it's the one
when did it shift from might be the one
to she is the one
well you know she had some stuff to
figure out for herself you know i
i was very certain from the get-go you
know
for whatever for whatever reason i just
knew from when we
literally from our first date but she
was quite cautious
and like don't forget she was she was
heading into summer house where she had
you know other complicated situations
going on so i think she was right to be
cautious
um i was there you know chatting to her
sometimes while she was in the house
kind of waiting for
her to let go i mean i was
i was not arrogant but i really felt
like eventually she would realize that
she needs to just let go and realize
that this is the thing
but uh i thought it was tricking me i
just couldn't wait for her to get out
you know because to me it felt like she
was in prison she was certainly an
appointment for me
so i just couldn't wait for her to get
out and for us to like experience it
together because it went from like oh
it's exciting i met somebody i like
to like an intense longing to like now
let's see if this is a real thing or if
it's just like
an intense facetime fling with somebody
who's in prison with
you know a bunch of you know insane
emotional situations
i wanted to have fun with you yeah and
instead you wasted my time
too i wasted your time okay cool to
finally be like choose your words wisely
wasted your time this is so awkward
doing what every day hannah we're
friends
he became my rock or like calling him
just felt so great
but i would normally cry the first 10
minutes on the call then we would have a
little phone sex
and then we would just talk about
everything and anything
so if i'm calling this guy crying every
night and he still
is falling for me and like maybe this is
meant to be
the phone's i just want to point out the
pawn six didn't happen straight away
that was
that was it he played hard to get he was
very hard
it was like i didn't give it up it
wasn't coming from me
let's establish the timeline here
because i do feel like there's this
conversation
happening with the viewers that are like
she came into the house she's having
these really strong feelings about luke
but now only so many months later she's
engaged the love of her life how does
this happen
i was crying not because i was
heartbroken i was crying out of
frustration and anger
after talking to sierra and realizing
this person that was taking up so much
of my time
was like lying about me and really did
not care
and wasn't the person i thought he was
so just want to make that clear but also
des and i met like two and a half weeks
before the show
we went on the dates i really liked him
i kept talking to him
when i got there um and we were
we were we had a very clear conversation
about
not being exclusive and all that so
there's there's actually there's no real
concerns about the timeline people can
have their perception about how she
felt about luke or not i mean let's
sometimes people ask me and i'm like
listen i don't care how much
somebody is an ex when you get stuck in
a house with somebody
that's that's emotional turmoil
i'm this terrible person i don't want to
cry like i'm so i'm in such a good place
in my life i don't need that
i really think that as des and i got
closer on the phone at night
it was really easy for me to be like oh
this situation is toxic
and never looking back and you'll see in
the house that my
actions definitely really changed
towards do you think we'll see dez
in a sh way shape or form on the show
this season
100 he you actually start to see some of
the phone calls
very soon and he comes to the house
oh you're like my girlfriend
holy sh this guy's old
guys are you watching the show i know
you didn't watch it before but are you
watching it with her week to week now
can i be honest about this yeah i'm not
watching the show
like even though i was very calm in our
discussion there
about luke who likes watching somebody
you know
deal with their feelings with their ex
you know like like i'm just not i'm not
into it but like
i think it's great you know i i think
the drama is great and all that
amazing you can tolerate him yelling at
you but i don't tolerate him yelling oh
there she goes
let's talk about my relationship let me
know when you actually are in a real
relationship
you're obsessed with luke you know what
i feel like sometimes with these things
it's like you don't really need to know
what your friends are saying about you
behind your back because we all say
stuff
that you don't want people to hear and
if you heard it it would be upsetting so
i don't need to hear it
i wish i didn't have to hear it but i
was gonna say we'll
jump around here a little bit there
there there is this
this learning that i don't know we
haven't seen if you're aware of it
or not yet but paige revealed herself to
be team amanda
in the you know aftermath of the blog
with kyle
i don't want to take sides
[Music]
but i'm kind of team amanda right now
please don't tell hannah she'll
literally murder me what was your
reaction to that
well it's not what she was saying to me
when we're cuddling a bed and she's just
like stand up for yourself and
he's not the boss of this house and i'm
proud of you so i was like but i also
think that paige knows that i'll forgive
her for anything i love her regardless
and
she didn't want to be on certain
people's bad sides so i get it
from a viewer's perspective that whole
fight felt like two wrongs to me like
everybody was wrong
have you do you have a different insight
into it it was a proud moment for anyone
but i also think that if you look deeper
we were not fighting about the things
that were being said
i think there's a there's deeper tension
in the house that you
that get more revealed okay
uh let's go back to this valentine's day
proposal
you've talked a lot about this video uh
that does filmed of singing and sending
to you
are we ever gonna get to see this video
no
no because that's a private mo you know
what i mean like hannah is
very bad at keeping anything private
it's like a
like a disease that she has that like it
has to be told to everybody or it's not
right why do you think i'm gonna
but that that's like a private that's
our thing that's a private moment for us
so i personally don't
want it for public consumption i think
if it was for public if it gets leaked
next week it wasn't me
it was hannah i mean who else would it
be
and uh the thing is that if it was for
public consumption i would have
done it differently i would have spent
days on it
well you know she said she was gonna air
the audio of the proposal video on
burning in hell so i don't know if that
had
been turned into just i i mean she's
like a rat you know that's just
there's no you just ratted her out which
is great honestly if she does she'll be
in big trouble so
like like not like i'm not going to
treat her like kyle and shout in her
face
but i i she will be in in big trouble
like i will be happy hannah do you have
to make some edits man what's up you're
so
crazy hannah i told you not to send
videos make your own videos
you're so lazy why are you sending out
the videos i did my hard work you're
sitting around doing nothing
sending out my videos is that your kyle
cook impression oh that's me
acting like kyle i'm not impersonating
come on
what does getting married mean to you
for like the future of you on reality tv
we've never seen someone on summer house
in a marriage we've seen committed
relationships but never a marriage
would you go and do it solo and leave
deaths behind
for the summer dez would you ever go do
summer house
you asked me if i would do a parry um
i i i like i i'm not pitching for
for being on summers i'll just follow
her lead really it's nothing to do with
me it's all her decision i mean i think
what's helped me in my reality tv career
thus far is just being like
very open very vulnerable wearing all my
emotions on my sleeve and i just have to
keep living my life and then if people
want to see it great and if they don't
i'll be on to the next thing so i think
i just have to keep doing
me and seeing if it entertains people or
not
would you film the wedding i think we're
on the fence with it
i think we're on the fence because i
have a lot of family that we're very
intimate with and like probably wouldn't
be interested in filming
um so we haven't even like thought about
that but
we we haven't even talked to bravo to be
honest do you have any fomo right now
not being in vermont i know we probably
can't talk about what's happening in
vermont but you have
i feel um i feel a sense of like
calmness
that um i'm not there for people to take
their anger out on and they actually
have to talk about their real issues
and i am very being very supportive i've
i'm
in text exchanges but ultimately
trying to stay out of it and be
supportive of people is it's kind of
refreshing after this last season of
summer house that i i got into
way more things than i wanted to like
what's the problem